we really wanted to have the protection
from a third dose before school starts
especially because we're at a point in
the pandemic where
you know i think a lot of other
protection measures aren't going to be
in place this year so the mother of two
took her son south of the border to get
the shots he's currently ineligible to
receive in ontario i have seen a few
people really through twitter who had
mentioned to me that this is an option
going to ogdensburg to get the vaccine
we didn't we didn't really want to do
that we assumed that it would eventually
be open in ontario so we kind of waited
and waited and waited gibbs who ran for
the ontario liberals in june's
provincial election posted this photo to
twitter calling out the government for a
delayed rollout of third doses global
news reached out to the ministry of
health requesting an interview with the
minister and received this response we
are reviewing nasty's most recent
guidance and will be providing details
for booster shots for this age group in
the coming days
last week health canada gave pfizer's
booster the stamp of approval to be used
on kids 5 to 11. on wednesday manitoba
expanded its eligibility criteria for
the third dose to include that age group
by protecting them we are also
protecting families epidemiologist nazim
muhajarin supports the expansion of
third dose eligibility criteria just as
we don't question about
putting a seat belt on when we get into
a car i don't think that we should be
really second guessing you know whether
we need a vaccine at this point in time
it is our insurance policy against any
threat to global being as for katie
gibbs our kids are still
in daycare and going to school
but we want to
take any extra levels of protection that
we can shalima maharaj global news